Hi, I'm Helen Thompson.
I'm a producer here at Science News.
This year for our year-end issue
we decided to ask our beat writers
what they're excited to cover next year.
And here's what they said.
I'm Emily Conover
I'm the physics writer for Science News.
So the big discovery this past year was the detection
of gravitational waves by the LIGO experiment.
And we expect to see more from them
in the coming year.
So that's really exciting.
Everyone is super pumped about
gravitational waves right now.
Well particle physics is sort of
in a weird state right now.
It's a little bit of -- uh --
people are starting to get anxious.
We know that there's a lot of stuff
that's still unexplained in particle physics.
Like we don't know what dark matter is --
this stuff that makes up
a large portion of the matter in the universe.
So scientists are starting to look in some
more out-of-the-way corners
for new physics.
Hi, I'm Tina Hesman Saey
I'm the molecular biology reporter for Science News.
CRISPR is a hot new molecular biology tool
that you may have heard of
because everybody is using it to edit genomes.
According to most scientists
CRISPR can do anything.
That's not exactly true,
but it can do a lot of stuff.
In 2017, you can expect, for instance,
to see clinical trials for cancer
starting out with CRISPR,
and also possibly bringing CRISPR back to its roots
to combat viruses like HIV and hepatitis.
I'm Thomas Sumner.
I'm the earth and environmental sciences
for Science News magazine.
About 66 million years ago,
there was a devastating disaster on Earth.
And about three-quarters of all plant and animal
species got wiped out in a geologic instant.
And that's been a mystery for decades
You might have heard in school that
everything died from a big space rock impact.
But not everybody believes that.
And so to help answer that question,
A team of researchers has gone back to the scene
of the crime, off the coast of Mexico,
this giant 200-kilometer across crater,
called Chicxulub.
They dropped three giant kind of legs into the sea,
jacked themselves out of the water
so they had a stable platform,
and then drilled straight down,
into what's called the peak ring --
it's this ring of mountains within the crater itself.
So this drilling project and a lot of other research
projects regarding this horrible extinction event
have already told us a lot.
But there's some big questions remaining
and a lot of the findings
are just making those questions even bigger.
So 2017 is going to be interesting one way or the other
whether or not we really solve
what killed the dinosaurs.
Hi, I'm Meghan Rosen,
and I'm a staff reporter at Science News.
So I cover everything from robots to dinosaurs
But this year I spent a lot of time
focusing on the Zika virus outbreak.
So this year we've learned a lot about
how Zika virus can affect a baby's brain and body,
but we don't yet have a vaccine.
I think the earliest we can expect
to see a vaccine for Zika is in 2018 or 2019.
Vaccines have already started working their way
through human safety trials,
so I'm hoping that we see some results in 2017.
Two or three years might seem like
a long time to wait for Zika vaccine,
but, in terms of vaccine development,
it's a really short timeline.
I'm Laura Sanders,
and I'm the neuroscience writer here at Science News.
One of the most interesting new technologies
that I've come across this year is call neural dust.
It's these tiny crystals that scientists can
implant, so far just in animals, that
can eavesdrop on nerve cell behavior, and ultimately
they hope, can even control nerve cell behavior.
Scientists are coming up with all of these different ways
to really figure out what brain cells are doing
and influence them in a way that
might actually help people
Hi, I'm Christopher Crockett,
and I'm the Astronomy writer at Science News.
It's always a really cool year
to be writing about Astronomy
We're always discovering new things,
and I'm sure 2017 will be no different.
But there are a few things coming up
that I'm really excited about.
The Juno mission's at Jupiter,
and it's been there since July.
But now it's going to really start
doing its regular science,
mapping the interior of Jupiter
getting a 3-D picture of what the biggest
planet in our solar system
is like on the inside.
But i think one of the coolest things
going on the solar system this year
is the end of the Cassini mission at Saturn.
After almost 20 years in space
and over a decade at Saturn,
the mission is  coming to an end.
The spacecraft is going to dive into Saturn,
plunge into its atmosphere.
It's going to be making measurements
and transmitting data as long as it can
until it's ... crushed to death.
These are just some of the stories
we'll be tracking in 2017.
Stay tuned to see if we're right,
and don't forget to subscribe to our channel.
[music]